let's say that you're a watermelon
farmer and you want to study how dense
the seeds are in your watermelon perhaps
you want to do this because over time
you're trying to breed watermelons that
have fewer seeds and you should see
whether you are actually making progress
and you don't want to cut open every
watermelon in your in your watermelon
farm or patch or whatever it might be
called because you want to sell most of
them you just want to sample a few
watermelons and then take samples of
those watermelons to figure out how
dense the seeds are and hope that those
that you can you can calculate
statistics on those samples that are
decent estimates of the parameters for
the population so let's start doing that
so let's say that you take these little
cubic inch chunks out of a random sample
of your watermelons and then you count
the number of seeds in them and you get
you have eight samples like this so in
one of them you found four seeds in the
next you found three five seven two nine
eleven and seven so this is a sample
just to make sure we're visualizing it
right if this is the population of all
of the chunks these little cubic I guess
you view this as a cubic inch the cubic
inch chunks in my entire watermelon farm
I'm sampling a very small sample of them
so I'm sampling a very small sample
maybe I could have had a million over
here a million chunks of watermelon
could have been produced from my farm
but I'm only sampling so Capital n would
be 1 million lowercase n is equal to 8
and once again you might want to have
more samples but this will make our math
easy now let's think about what
statistics we can measure well the first
one that we often do is a measure of
central tendency and that's the
arithmetic mean but here we were trying
to estimate the population mean by
coming up with the sample mean the
sample mean so what is the sample mean
going to be well let's list all we have
to do is add up these points add up
these these measurements and then divide
number of measurements we have so let's
get our calculator out for that actually
I actually maybe I don't need my
calculator let's see so 4 plus 3 is 7 7
plus 5 is 12 12 plus 7 is 19 19 plus 2
is 21 plus 9 is 30 plus 11 is 41 plus 7
is 48 so I'm going to get 48 over 8 data
points so this worked out quite well
48 divided by 8 is equal to 6 so our
sample mean is 6 it's our estimate of
what the population mean might be but we
also want to think about how much in our
population we want to estimate how much
in our population how much how much does
how much spread is there how much do our
measurements on how much do they vary
from this mean so there we say well we
can try to estimate the population
variance by calculating the sample
variance and we're going to calculate
the unbinds but the unbiased sample
variance hopefully we're fairly
convinced at this point why we divide by
n minus 1 so we're going to calculate
the unbiased sample variance and if we
do that what do we get well it's just
going to be I'll do sin a different
color it's going to be 4 minus 6 squared
plus 3 minus 6 squared plus 5 minus 6
squared plus 7 minus 6 squared plus 2
minus 6 squared plus 9 minus 6 squared
plus 11 minus 6 squared plus 7 minus 6
squared all of that divided by not by 8
remember we want the unbiased sample
variance we're going to divide it by 8
minus 1 so we're going to divide by 7
and so this is going to be equal to let
me give myself a little bit more real
estate the samp unbiased sample variance
that I could even denote it by this to
make it clear that we're dividing by
lowercase n minus 1 is going to be equal
to let's see 4 minus 6 is negative 2
that squared is positive 4 so I did that
1 3 minus 6 is negative 3 that squared
is
to be 9 5 minus 6 squared is 1 squared
which is 1 7 minus 6 is once again 1
squared which is 1 2 minus 6 negative 4
squared negative 4 squared is 16
9 minus 6 squared well that's going to
be 9 11 minus 6 squared that is 25 25
and then finally 7 minus 6 squared
that's another one and we're going to
divide it by 7 now let's see if we can
add this up in our heads 4 plus 9 is 13
plus 1 is 14 15 31 40 65 66 so this is
going to be equal to 66 over 7 and we
could either divide because that's nine
and 3/7 we could write that as 9 and 3/7
or if we want to write that as a decimal
I can just take 66 66 divided by 7 gives
us 9 point I'll just round it so it's
approximately 9 point 4 3 so this is
approximately nine point nine point four
three now that gave us our unbiased
sample variance well how could we
calculate a sample standard deviation we
want to somehow get at an estimate of
what the population standard deviation
might be well the logic should I guess
is reasonable to say well this is our
unbiased sample variance it's our best
estimate of what the true population
variance is when we think about
population parameters to get the
population standard deviation to get the
population standard deviation we just
take the square root of the population
variance so if we want to get an
estimate of the sample standard
deviation why don't we just take the
square root of the unbiased sample
variance the unbiased sample variance so
that's what we'll do so we'll define it
that way we'll call the sample standard
deviation we're going to define
it to be equal to the square root of the
unbiased sample variance so it's going
to be the square root of this quantity
and we could take our calculator out
it's going to be the square root of what
I just typed in I can do second answer
it'll be the last entry here so square
root of that is and I'll just round it's
approximately equal to three point two
zero seven approximately equal to three
point zero seven now I'm going to tell
you something very counterintuitive or
at least initially it's counterintuitive
but hopefully you'll appreciate this
over time this we've already talked
about in some depth we've even had
people have even created simulations to
show that this is an unbiased estimate
of population variance when we divided
by n minus one and that's a good
starting point we're going to take the
square root of anything but it actually
turns out that because the square root
the square root function is nonlinear
that this sample standard deviation the
sample standard deviation and this is
how it tends to be defined sample
standard standard deviation that this
sample standard deviation which is the
square root the square root of the
square root of our of our sample
variance so from I equals 1 to N of our
unbiased sample variance so divided by n
minus 1 this is how we literally divide
our sample standard deviation because
the square root function is nonlinear
this is nonlinear non linear it turns
out that this is not an unbiased
estimate of the true population standard
deviation and I encourage people to make
simulations of that if they're
interested but then you might say okay
well we went through great pains to
divide by n minus 1 here in order to get
an unbiased estimate of the population
variance why don't we go through similar
pains and somehow figure out a formula
for an unbiased estimate of the
population standard deviation and the
reason why that's difficult is to unbias
the sample variance we just have to
divide by n minus 1 instead of n and
that
worked for any any pop just probability
distribution for our population it turns
out to do the same thing for the
standard deviation it's not that easy
it's actually dependent on how that
population is actually distributed so in
statistics we just define the sample
standard deviation and the one that we
use is based we typically use is based
on the square root of the unbiased
sample variance but when you take that
square root it does introduce it is a it
does give you a biased result when
you're estimating for the cent when
you're trying to use this to estimate
the population standard deviation but
it's the simplest best tool we have